ein bruch mit dem deutschland vor so wie
wir es in den letzten jahren kannten
ganz bewusst ein bruch mit dem makel
jahren nein ich würde auch nicht sagen
eine brücke in die gegenwart in die neue
zeit und eine brücke über die vielleicht
in großen schritten auf holz aufholen
schritte passieren können all das was
liegen geblieben ist
zeitgemäß zu reformieren das klang bei
ihnen ein bisschen entschieden sie haben
nämlich davon gesprochen dass man den
status quo in deutschland überwinden
müsse das ist ja mehr auch zum beispiel
als das was gerhard schröder 98 gesagt
hatte dieses berühmte wort wir wollen
nicht alles anders aber vieles besser
machen das wären für die ampel zu wenig
gewesen
ich will jetzt gar keine historischen
vergleich bemüht aber wir haben doch
auch jetzt während der pandemie gesehen
dass unser staat nicht in der weise
handlungsfähig ist ja dass sein sollte
wir beklagen defizite bei der
öffentlichen infrastruktur des
bildungssystems nicht so gut wie es sein
soll unsere wirtschaft weniger
wettbewerbsfähig als sie sein muss um
soziale sicherheit auch in zukunft zu
garantieren
außerdem wollen wir uns gemeinsam der
großen herausforderung der
transformation stellen die aufgrund des
klimaschutzes nötig ist und da meine ich
müssen wir den status quo überwinden das
ist aber kein bruch sondern ich glaube
dass unser land viel zu gewinnen hat sie
sagen kein bruch sie scheuen historische
vergleich aber der koalitionsvertrag ist
voller großer worte freiheit
gerechtigkeit nachhaltigkeit mut
zuversicht also dass klingelt geradezu
aus dem papier aus robert habeck spricht
sogar davon eine lernende politik muss
in dem lernenden deutschland dienen ging
es nicht herr lindner für sie ganz
banalen erstmal darum einen linksrutsch
in deutschland zu verhindern
wir wollen nach vorne gestalten und wir
sind jetzt nicht mehr im wahlkampf ich
glaube dass die leute auch jetzt nicht
mehr behelligt werden wollen mit
parteipolitischer rhetorik sondern jetzt
geht es darum probleme zu lösen ich
erinnere daran dass wir in einer
dramatischen
gesundheitskrise unverändert sind viele
andere herausforderungen stehen vor uns
richtig ist es ist eine regierung der
mitte das land nach vorne bringt und ich
glaube wir sind gut beraten auch die
interessen und anliegen der menschen zu
berücksichtigen die jetzt nicht grün
oder sozialdemokratisch oder liberal
gewählt haben sondern zb cdu und csu
auch die sollen sich mit dieser
bundesregierung in diesem land gut
regiert fühlen dann vielleicht ja doch
noch mal ein bisschen hand aufs herz sie
haben heute ihre lernkurve beschworen
die diskretion beschworen die manche
inzwischen auch schon geheimniskrämerei
genannt haben er habe ganz ehrlich mal
wie eng war es denn zwischendurch hinter
den verschlossenen türen von ihnen wurde
mal unmut sozusagen berichtet jedenfalls
es gehe beim klima mit der fdp nicht
weit genug so vor drei wochen haben sie
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen raus tickern
lassen würde ich mal unterstellen wir
gar nicht reden wie kritisch was das ist
die frage zwischendurch waren sie mal an
dem punkt sind den lindner zu machen und
wo möglich auszusteigen nein
zu der besonderen leistung gehört da
will ich mir sicher dass niemand aus dem
näheren verhandlungsteam irgendetwas hat
ausgelassen ich will nicht ausschließen
dass zu einer art über shop effekt
irgendwo gegeben hat irgendjemand
irgendwie mal was erzählt was 34 tage
her war und der hatte so erzählt und
dann so aber eine bewusste indiskretion
aus der engeren verhandlungsrunde
schließlich geradezu aus und das ist
eine qualität und eine qualität die
nicht selbstverständlich ist und egal
wie wir uns erst mal finden müssen
inhaltlich dass loyalität und integrität
und verlässlichkeit sich bewiesen haben
dass wird man sagen müssen und es hat
schon das war jetzt nicht immer nur
leise und ausgewogen argumentiert also
der zwanglose zwang des besseren
argumente des nach jürgen habermas so
war es nicht immer es ging auch mal wir
sind jetzt 14 tage sind seit 14 tagen
kaum klare und robuste charaktere wenn
ich das sagen darf natürlich hat man
auch schon mal
rhetorisch ein bisschen zugelangt aber
sich auch immer wieder eingefangen und
das ist das interessante gewesen dass
wir das nicht noch kurz zu ende wenn man
wenn man sich zehn mal gesagt hat dass
man nicht nur hand ist und beim zwölften
mal nachfragt wie kommt die eigentlich
zu eurer meinung und dann wird es
erklärt und dann versteht man was die
andere seite eigentlich antreibt dann
öffnet sich auf einmal im korridor
hinter der
russischen dollar rhetorik und wissen
dann was gut bisschen gruppendynamik gab
es offenbar schon herr lindner ihr
partei-vize kubicki hatte am letzten
wochenende gesagt es brauche bei den
grünen einen hohen pädagogischen aufwand
um zu vernünftigen lösungen zu kommen
das was robert da gerade geschildert hat
ist dass dieser aufwand wie viel aufwand
haben sie dabei treiben müssen oder hat
das robert habeck für sie erledigt ich
mache mir das zitat von meinem freund
wolfgang kubicki nicht zu eigen es ging
ohne pädagogik wir haben in der sache
gut gesprochen und selbstverständlich
haben unsere gesprächspartnerin und
gesprächspartner von spd und grünen ihr
programm und ihre überzeugungen
vertreten das haben wir auch wirklich
grad über der atmosphäre hat zwar
geknirscht waren sie an den punkt wo sie
gesagt haben freund halberg oder robert
vorsicht hier ist unsere linie wir waren
und sind uns alle des ernstes der lage
bewusst
anders als etwa
2017 gibt es auch keine andere
tragfähige regierungskoalition das muss
man in erinnerung rufen cdu und csu sind
gegenwärtig auch gar nicht in der lage
eine regierung zu tragen und deshalb gab
es zum gelingen dieser gespräche keine
alternative und sie sind jetzt zufrieden
mit dem was sie durchgesetzt haben habe
ich sie vielleicht nicht denn viele
sagen jetzt schon diese ampel blinkt
sehr geld
ich habe das nach dem seinen jungs
papier mit einem gewissen erstaunen zur
kenntnis genommen weil ich das schon
diesem papier nach nicht da gerecht fand
ich glaube dass wir jetzt mit dem
koalitionsvertrag ein dokument vorgelegt
haben das
die die besten ideen und konzepte von
allen parteien vereinigt und ich bin
zufrieden und stolz wir haben im moment
nur noch bei der atmosphäre sie
präsentieren sich auch hier als team
außergewöhnlich genug
es fiel heute mittag bei der
präsentation auf das sie ich spreche
jetzt persönlich anna lindner leicht
gönnerhaft der spd und den grünen
erklärt haben dass ich stolz sein können
auf das verhandlungsergebnis und olaf
scholz haben sie für seine erfahrung und
professionalität gelobt fast wie beim
noten verteilen zu hause die demo die
sie dann später gefordert haben die war
da nicht mehr wahr
ich bin überrascht dass der ausdruck von
respekt und fairness von manchen wie
ihnen in gönnerhaft ich keitum
interpretiert wird
sie meinen so konnte man das gar nicht
verstehen so wollten sie es nicht gesagt
haben ich habe dazu ihr habe ich jetzt
geäußert
die roten ein bisschen aus wie wird
dieses verhältnis sein das merken sie
und dazu gehört ja auch dass wenn auch
die posten namentlich noch nicht besetzt
sind das wurde heute glaube ich schon
sehr deutlich dass christian lindner das
amt des finanzministers übernehmen wird
in dieser regierung und herr habeck die
frage an sie wie sehr schmerzt sie das
denn sie haben auch im wahlkampf klar
gemacht die würden dieses amt nun auch
sehr gerne übernehmen war das im grunde
vielleicht der größte preis den sie der
fdp geben mussten um an diese regierung
einzutreten das finanzministerium ist im
besten fall ein ermöglichung ministerium
und im schlimmsten fall ein
verhinderungs ministerium der einfluss
hatte und wir haben in dem
koalitionsvertrag und in den gesprächen
drumherum all das was ermöglicht werden
soll und muss vor allem jetzt aus
unserer und meiner sicht die investition
in eine
klimaneutrale gesellschaft industrie
infrastruktur
verabredet verbindlich verabredet die
finanziellen ressourcen dafür
identifiziert und reserviert dafür und
der geist der gespräche lässt eine
einseitige für mögliche
behinderung nicht mehr zu insofern ist
das völlig in ordnung dass die fdp das
finanzministerium hat und wir wir
schaffen jetzt zu sagen die die
möglichkeiten anderen häusern zu
gestalten alles gut verhinderungs
ministerium da sie haben sie eingehalten
nein ich habe nur zufällig als das wort
viel angezeigt dass sie auch gerne dazu
stellung nehmen will robert habeck hat
recht es wird jetzt sehr viel ermöglicht
an öffentlichen vorhaben und
investitionen im übrigen wird es auch
entlastungen geben zum
1.1.2013 und 20 entfällt die sogenannte
eeg-umlage beim strompreis für jede
familie für jeden mittelständischen
betrieb ist das eine entlastung in
milliarden höhe das wollen wir gemeinsam
ermöglichen und zugleich und das wort
verhindern zu nehmen verhindern wir dass
deutschland die stabilitätspolitik
verlässt wir haben ja bereits eine
geldentwertung viele menschen sind
besorgt wegen dieser inflation eines und
das wichtigste mittel dagegen ist dass
der staat solide mit dem geld umgeht und
das ist gesichert denn es gibt keine
steuererhöhungen und die schuldenbremse
die werden wir respektieren und ab 23
einhalten und trotzdem mit unserem
ehrgeiz und der ambition die vielen
guten vorhaben finanzieren aber es ist
genau so dass sie natürlich als
finanzminister ein vetorecht haben wenn
sie herr habe und dass davon gehen alle
aus ein ministerium für wirtschaft und
klima also das große klimaministerium
übernehmen haben sie sich das auch
ausbildungen werden sie ein vetorecht
haben lassen sie mich ganz kurz noch mal
den finanzen verweilen was ich meinte
wir haben für den investiven bereich
verschiedene möglichkeiten geschaffen
die jetzt quasi vor der klammer stehen
es werden gesellschaften ertüchtigt die
dann selber kreditfähig werden selber
investieren können das ist dann nicht
mehr der bundeshaushalt sondern sind
gesellschaften die etwas bauen einnahmen
haben weil ihre kredite wieder tilgen
wir haben einen großen fonds aufgelegt
der gut gefüllt ist es also ja alles
fest verabredet es gibt die kfw bank
also da haben wir genug möglichkeiten
geschaffen dass ich guten glaubens und
dem vertrauen das wir sehr gut
zusammenarbeiten werden sollte ich
wirtschaftsminister sein sollte ich für
eine prosperierende wirtschaft die
steuereinnahmen fließen zu christian
gentner r wird sie gut verwaltung und
wieder zurück wenn die bevölkerung
sehr gut verabredet an hat macht die
konkrete frage gibt es ein vetorecht für
irgendjemanden 1 1 also das vetorecht
des finanzministers ist im grundgesetz
vorgesehen solche dinge wollten wir
nicht tun dass wir auch unnötig gewesen
wir wollen ja gut zusammenarbeiten wir
haben aber einen mechanismus etabliert
wir haben jetzt klima check genannt dass
jedes gesetzesvorhaben auf seine
klimawirkung
überprüft werden muss das ist dann in
der gesetzesvorlage zu verzeichnen
gegebenenfalls zu erklären warum es
hinzunehmen ist und natürlich kann das
dann auch gegen überprüft werden und
sollte das dann hinderlich sein aber
nennt sich der finanzminister im
kabinett keine einstimmigkeit jeder
gesetzentwurf muss von allen parteien
getragen werden das war schon vorher so
also wenn man sagt ich will nicht die
gelbe seiten die grüne seite stimmt
nicht zu dann stimmt halt nicht wird
halt nicht zugestimmt außer es steht im
koalitionsvertrag dann ist die frage wer
ist jetzt durch und jetzt hat man ein
instrument geschaffen diese es konkret
zu beziehen auf eine art klima
mainstreaming wenn man so will also sie
haben ein paar gesetze sind nur das veto
recht so eingeschränkt dass eben erklärt
hat dafür ist er vize kanzler haben wir
so richtig verstanden über
den haushalt entscheidet der deutsche
bundestag also das parlament entscheidet
darüber wo die öffentlichen mittel
eingesetzt wird das ist richtig so das
bleibt so ein grund warum wir
zurückhaltend waren uns sind bei
nebenhaushalten die der direkten
parlamentarischen kontrolle nicht mehr
zugänglich sind ich beabsichtige nicht
mit der fdp in einer regierung
einzutreten
die das ziel hat nur miteinander zu
streiten sondern man muss sich einigen
auf gemeinsame vorhaben und übrigen muss
man auch vertragstreu sein ich glaube
nicht dass wir
ankündigen sollten die öffentlichkeit zu
behelligen mit streit wer an welches
welches vetorecht hat ich würde ja nur
ein jahr anhalten wir wollen ja nichts
verbieten sondern wir wollen ermöglichen
aber es kotzt aber es gibt nur einen
vizekanzler darüber wurde ja mal
gesprochen das ist zwei vize kanzler
geben könnte damals wetter reicht und
sie sind darüber wurde in den medien
spekuliert was mich etwas überrascht hut
weil die formulierung in unserer
verfassung ist eindeutig es gibt einen
stellvertreter der bundeskanzlerin oder
den bundeskanzler und das ist der chef
der zweitgrößten partei
das würden wir alles abwarten hinzu wird
es gut aber das bleiben sie ja der chef
der zweitgrößten partei also damit es
sozusagen das bleibe ich eben nicht weil
unsere satzung vorsieht dass wir nicht
bundesminister und parteivorsitzender
sein können für eine übergangszeit okay
aber nicht die
zeit als parteivorsitzender endlich nein
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe ist noch
nicht klar wer vizekanzler wird dh es
kann auch noch anna lena berger werden
meint dass es geklärt aber wir müssen
den koalitionsvertrag jahren von unseren
mitgliedern und da würde ich gerne drauf
haben bis das soweit ist mitten im
übergang zwischen alter und neuer
regierung ist die korona krise
dramatisch wie nie darüber wurde heute
mittag auch ausführlich gesprochen
höchste instanz eine überlastete
krankenhäuser mangelnde impfmöglichkeit
auch beim fußball es wurde viel von
aufbruch geredet aber ist es nicht so
dass die ampel schon an der ersten
bewährungsprobe gescheitert ist und dass
sie die bürger in dieser phase in den
letzten drei vier wochen im stich
gelassen haben
das würde eine verdrehung der tatsachen
sondern aus meiner sicht denn wir haben
ja eine amtierende regierung die
amtierenden minister beziehen ihre
gehälter sie machen weiter sie stehen in
der verantwortung die sollen das heißt
amtierende oder geschäftsführer
regierung sie solle jetzt nicht noch
neue projekte anschieben die die nächste
regierung über die nächsten drei jahre
oder 30 jahre bin aber sie soll
natürliche amtsgeschäfte machen und
zudem amtsgeschäft eines
gesundheitsministers gehörten einer
pandemie die bevölkerung zu informieren
die richtigen ratschläge zu geben die
gewichtigen gesetze vorzubereiten die
verteilung von impfdosen zu organisieren
und wenn jemand die indirekten zugang zu
statistiken hat dann der die
geschäftsführende also in dem sie dann
amtierende regierung in der tat haben
diese sind werden wir als regierung
gesehen und wollen wir auch wir stellen
uns ja der verantwortung und haben
deswegen eine infektionsschutzgesetz vor
einer woche durch den bundestag gebracht
das den ländern und kommunen mehr
differenzierte möglichkeiten gibt als
jemals zuvor werden würden die ganze
würden die entschlossen angewandt werden
und man fragt sich eher warum sie so
lange nicht angewandt wurden wenn vieles
ging schon davor man muss nicht karneval
feiern wo sich alle feiern selig in den
armen liegen um danach zu sagen wir
müssen noch weitere härtere maßnahmen
ergreifen damit könnten wir die vierte
welle brechen und die frage war ja schon
und der vorwurf haben sie die richtigen
signale gegeben also die das auslaufen
lassen der epidemischen notlage die fdp
hat vom freedom der im märz gesprochen
das war natürlich schon signale die
jetzt im nachhinein gewertet wurden als
falsch also der vorwurf sie haben sich
sehr viel mit koalition natürlich jetzt
beschäftigt und mit sich selbst und
haben das nicht ernst genug genommen zu
einem frühzeitigen
zeitpunkt stimmt so gar nicht wie viel
ich zurückweisen
auch der jetzt geschäftsführende
bundesgesundheitsminister hat ja
gesprochen über
den rechtsbegriff der epidemischen
notlage es handelt sich dabei nicht um
die bezeichnung von speziellen
instrumenten müssen rechtsbegriff
ich bin kein freund von
wechselseitigen schuldzuweisungen können
wir die ganze sendung bestreiten damit
warum haben wir beim booster und also
den auffrischungsimpfungen nicht den
stand den wir bräuchten und anderes mehr
wem hilft dass wir müssen jetzt handeln
dass die werden die hatten ihn die
bundeskanzlerin offenbar ins gewissen
geredet allen zusammen und zug ist jetzt
zu lesen einen sofortigen locker und
gefordert warum haben sie das
ausgeschlagen ihre darstellung ist so
nicht richtig aber ich berichte trotzdem
nicht aus internen gesprächen jetzt geht
es ja darum diese lage zu bewältigen wir
haben verabredet und bitten auch die
jetzt geschäftsführer bundesregierung
bereits darum anständigen krisenstab
einzurichten
der auf tagesbasis lage bewertet
massnahmen anordnet es kann nicht sein
dass nur in zeitlichen abstand von
mehreren wochen eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
zusammenkommt die lage ist dramatisch es
muss gehandelt werden ich sage ein
zweites wir müssen beim impfen und
boostern gesamtstaatlich besser werden
aber es gibt auch den dringenden appell
an die bürgerinnen und bürger da
brauchen wir nicht noch behördliche
anordnungen für sonst können wir hier
machen können hier appellieren wir
müssen alle unsere kontakte einschränken
es ist jetzt nicht die zeit für
ausgelassene weihnachtsfeiern denn der
gesellige mensch der welt privat jetzt
ist nicht der zeitpunkt der nachfrage
können sie sich vorstellen ein szenario
wo sie am ende doch auch einer
impfpflicht zustimmen eine einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht allgemeine
helmpflicht sowie der grüne
ministerpräsident kretschmann sich das
vorstellen kann wie das kurz darstellen
zu beginn der pandemie haben alle von
der bundeskanzlerin bis zur fdp
impfpflicht ausgeschlossen warum bei
verfassungsrechtler rinnen und
verfassungsrechtler gesagt haben es sei
nicht verhältnismäßig diesen eingriff in
die selbstbestimmung auf der anderen
seite weil praktiker aus einrichtungen
berichtet haben da gab es die
befürchtung wenn es zu einer impfpflicht
etwa in pflegeeinrichtungen kommt dass
beschäftigte den arbeitsplatz verlassen
diese
ratschläge an die politik haben sich
verändert also ändert sich das urteil
der politik über die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht bei der allgemeinen
impfpflicht möchte ich erst einmal
abwarten wie sich verfassungsrechtler
darzustellen das ist hochumstritten
und erst wenn es da eine beurteilung
gibt ob es überhaupt möglich wäre
konjunktiv ist danach politisch zu
entscheiden ob man es will
aber reine spekulation hilfe nicht aber
sie wollen
erstmal muss man sagen wenn wir heute
eine allgemeine impfpflicht hätten wir
hätten das gleiche desaster dass wir im
moment erleben und
christian lindner hat aus meiner sicht
zu recht auf die debatte auf die das
auslaufen der epidemische notlage
hingewiesen die
auch eine debatte war hinter der man
sich auch gut verstecken konnte weil ja
viele maßnahmen die in der gesetzgebung
möglich gewesen dann trotzdem nicht
erlassen wurden also die nachfrage war
ja immer wenn das jetzt ausläuft welche
maßnahme ist dann brauchen nicht mehr
möglich antwort keine keine maßnahme
darauf gegründet nun ist diese
impfpflicht erst einmal eine debatte
über die man sehr laut und meinungsstark
diskutieren kann aber sie löst nicht das
problem haben wir genug impfstoff wird
er gut verteilt werden das derzeitige
akute so ist es und wir müssen das akute
problem lösen also die die morgan
eingeführte impfpflicht löst für
übermorgen exakt null probleme weil wir
das gleiche gehäuse verfügt über
insgesamt verbaute ich würde ich für
mich sagen sehen ja dass die impfquote
in deutschland zu gering ist wenn es
immer nur ein pendeln zwischen lockdown
und öffnung gibt trotz der der
möglichkeit zu impfen dann wird man sich
dieser debatte annähern müssen aber so
wie christian lindner gesagt hat
verfassungsrechtlich prüfen die
voraussetzungen schaffen ich meine
stellen sie sich vor es gibt keine
impfpflicht und das geimpft sein ist
voraussetzung zur teilnahme an
öffentlichen leben und die leute gegend
ein impfstoff dann rasten sie alle
komplett ausgang zu recht da er sonst
ein ernsthaftes thema ist eher eine
sache noch sagen wir müssen jetzt
handeln die impfpflicht ist gegenwärtig
keine
option die bereits politisch von einer
regierung oder werden regierung geprüft
wird und deshalb sollten wir die
debatten nicht immer neu mit themen
beschweren die uns in der momentanen
situation nicht helfen sondern eher die
situation erschweren es gibt jetzt ein
anderes krisen-management ich sagte dass
eben dargestellt wir brauchen mehr
konsequenz tägliches testen
einrichtungen einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht wird vorbereitet masken
werden zurückkommen zweig regeln ich
glaube wir werden regional auch schafe
kontakt beschränkungen bekommen bei
hohen instanzen unvermeidlich eine
lesenswerte mit dem ziel mit dem ziel
frau schausten dass wir nicht in einen
kompletten stillstand kommen weil auch
der einen hohen sozialen auch
wirtschaftlichen preis hat hohe schäden
das muss verhindert werden wissen beide
meine hand das zu dieser sendung die
satz ergänzung gehört wir geben einen
kurzen halbsatz vor sie ergänzen ihnen
bitte möglichst kurz und wir versuchen
noch ein paar themen bitte kurz in
diesem sinn abzuhalten habe kann sie
dies der erste halbsatz bitte kurz
ergänzung auf das verkehrsministerium
unter grüner leitung zu verzichten
wäre nur nicht möglich gewesen wenn wir
20 prozent bekommen hätten dass der
staat den wohnungsmarkt mit der
mietpreis bremse weiter reguliert
war eine ein anliegen unserer
gesprächspartner aber die fortschreibung
einer politik die auch die union
mitgetragen hat scheint mir
verantwortbar
habe die legalisierung von cannabis als
fortschritts projekt auszurufen
beendet den schwarzmarkt schützt
schützt
und gibt dem staat genug einnahmen um
aufklärung und präventionskampagnen zu
fahren nochmal herbeck wenn immer mehr
europäische partner aus
klimaschutzgründen auf atomkraft setzen
hat deutschland sich dennoch entschieden
einen anderen weg zu gehen das ist
beispiellos in europa entweder kohle und
erneuerbaren energien oder atom und
erneuerbare energien wir werden das
andere beweisen müssen und wenn wir das
beweisen
zeigen wir der welt eine gute
alternative auf erleben da sie haben es
eben schon mal angeklickten lassen die
sie sich den posten als finanzminister
vorstellen stabilität seriosität sie
wissen dass es in der eu und vor allem
in frankreich vorbehalte gibt auch gegen
sie als person was kommt da ihnen wird
ein restriktiver finanzpolitischer kurs
unterstellt keine gemeinsame schulden
keine transfers in ärmere länder werden
sie sich in der amtsführung er am
sparsam wolfgang schäuble orientieren
oder am ich sag mal flexibleren urlaub
schon die zeiten ändern sich man kann
die aktuelle situation in europa nach
der pandemie jetzt nicht vergleichen mit
2010 oder mit 2018 deshalb muss man
eigene antworten finden klar ist dass
deutschland eine hohe verantwortung in
der europäischen union und in der
wirtschafts- und währungsunion hat wir
sind das wirtschaftlich stärkste land
aus dieser besonderen verantwortung
leite ich zweierlei erstens
wir müssen für stabilität sorgen denn
kann inflation wir sind ein alternder
kontinent da können die staatsschulden
auch nicht in den himmel wachsen weil
dann die lasten auf den schultern der
einzelnen menschen zu groß werden auf
der anderen seite haben wir aber eben
auch eine verantwortung dafür dass
dieser
währungsraum zusammenbleibt dass es
investitionen auch in anderen ländern
ergibt und dass insgesamt auch politisch
stabilität herrscht das heißt unser land
kann nicht agieren wie ein kleineres
nordisches land wir können uns aber auch
nicht einseitig an die seite derjenigen
stellen die die wirtschafts und
währungsunion und ihre regeln aushöhlen
wollen das heißt wir haben so etwas wie
eine dienende führungsrolle so und das
war jetzt fast schon die
regierungserklärung des finanzministers
die des ministers für klimaschutz hören
wir beim nächsten mal denn das ist ja
noch nicht offiziell dann ist die zeit
schon um wir danken sehr was nun herr
herberg vielen dank herr lindner das
alles aussagen wir den zuschauern nach 2
g + regeln das muss gesagt sein in der
heutigen zeit danke für ihr interesse
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit dem zdf
spezial und matthias fornoff
[Musik]